hey you guys
just me on the movie retrospective today
because at the time that i
am recording this uh tom is still sick
with that food poisoning thing that i
told you guys about i'm feeling
mostly better but you know not all the
way but this kind of had to get recorded
today
so he hasn't got out of bed all day so
i'm just like are you
gonna be able to do this and he's like
no i was like okay well i'll just do it
by myself
uh you know no big so the movie that
we're gonna be talking about
today i'm so so excited that this one
finally got uh chosen in the poll
because this is a movie that i saw
a bunch of times you know back probably
in the early 80s like when i was a kid
and it actually really made a big
impression on me
and uh i had but then i hadn't seen it
for a really really long time at least
20 years or more
and i feel like it's one that kind of
gets forgotten about
um it doesn't really get talked about
all that much
except in the sense of you know the
controversy that it caused i guess
uh but this is the 1976 film the little
girl who lives down the lane
now this is i am i'm not sure what genre
i would call this
it's nominally like a thriller mystery
type of thing has some horror elements i
think it did win a saturn award for best
horror movie that year so it does have
that going for it too
almost like a little bit of a character
study it's really weird because i think
that
the first time that i saw it and i could
be totally remembering that's wrong
i probably should have looked it up but
uh it reminded me
a lot of this book i think is ian mcewen
i think it was called the cement garden
was that not about like a bunch of kids
whose parent parents had died or they
had killed them i can't remember
and um they were trying to like fake
their parents still being alive so
people wouldn't [ __ ] with them so they
could stay in their house
so they had put the bodies like in this
big
trunk or something like that they filled
with cement i don't remember but um
that made a book made a big impression
on me too and this one this movie is
kind of along the same lines
all right so as i said this movie came
out in 1976 it was directed by
nicholas guess gessner who is uh
hungarian born but
from what i could determine from his
wikipedia page has made almost
exclusively uh french films he worked in
france most of his life
and um this was also a
french canadian co-production they shot
it in canada
and you know they got the tax shelter
and everything and then they got money
from the french government as well
now it's based on a novel uh that was
called the same thing which came out in
1974. now the novel was written by laird
koenig
and i haven't read the book i do want to
get a little bit into but from you know
i've read summaries of it so i do want
to get into a little bit of you know
maybe the differences
but i think what initially ended up
happening was that larry
koenig actually wrote this first
as a screenplay and then he
shortly became to realize he's like well
there's no way that i could have like a
little girl
who's supposed to be 12 or 13 years old
like an actress
playing this role night after night you
know what i mean if it's
if it was a you know play that was long
running or whatever he's like i couldn't
ask
anybody to do that so i guess his agent
said why don't you turn it into a novel
so he turned it into a novel and then
turned it into a screenplay he also
wrote the screenplay for this
now most famously this was probably the
first starring role
of jody foster now she was 13
when she made this um as she is in the
movie she's playing the age that she is
in the movie now she had been in some
movies before this obviously she had
been in a
freaky friday she'd been on you know
some tv and stuff i think she was acting
from
a very young age maybe four or five
years old and had done like tv and
commercials and [ __ ] like that
i think that she came to the attention
of the producers of this film
after they saw her in alice doesn't live
here anymore
where she wasn't a starring role but she
was you know kind of a big part of that
story
and uh they're like yeah that's her they
apparently she didn't even need to
um audition for the role or anything
because there's like yeah that's who we
want
because basically what they needed for
this particular role
in the little girl who lives down the
lane is a girl
who you know was basically a tween
but who was believably very
intelligent and resourceful way beyond
her years also like a little bit
cold and calculating but not in an
off-putting way if that makes any sense
and so she is like perfect in this and
honestly
i had forgotten like watching this movie
again it's on amazon prime by the day by
the way it wasn't hulu
because that's where i first i was
scrolling through hulu and i was like oh
man they've got that and that's why i
put it in the poll
but then when i went to actually watch
it it wasn't there anymore so but
luckily it's still on amazon prime or at
least
you know it is at this recording so if
you want to watch it you can go check it
out although
i'm going to spoil it so you know what i
mean but i feel bad doing that but
the movie's so old that i don't know i i
just kind of feel like maybe a lot of
people haven't seen it
and this is one movie that i think it's
kind of
good to go into it not really knowing
what's going on
although maybe audiences nowadays would
be a lot more savvy and they'd be able
to figure out what's going
on i don't know so um so yeah so this is
jody foster's
probably her first starring role um this
same year she actually did taxi driver
which i think she even got an
oscar for an oscar nomination and she
was in bugsy malone
so she had like five movies like come
out in 1976 but i think this was maybe
the first one to come out and the first
one with
her in the starring role and as i
mentioned before
you can really tell that this screenplay
was originally written as a play
because a lot of the scenes probably
like 95
of the scenes take place inside the
house
and you know in the front room mostly
like the living room of the house
there's a few scenes outside and
everything like that and usually there's
only
two or three characters interacting at a
time and i'm not even saying that like
to be denigrating or anything like that
i think it works really well because it
has like this really
it has this really cool like atmosphere
i guess that a lot of those movies
had back in the 70s just is kind of like
creepy what the [ __ ] is going on type of
thing
all right so let's get into what this
movie is about
so jody foster plays a 13 year old girl
named wren jacobs now
apparently to all uh appearances
her and her father lester have recently
moved i believe
she says it was two months prior have
recently moved to this little town
like i said they shot it in canada but i
think it's supposed to be somewhere in
maine like a fictional town in maine or
something somewhere up in the northeast
so her dad have moved into this house
um the dad has paid the lease for three
years
for them to stay in this house now at
the very beginning of the
movie uh wren jody foster's character
is making a birthday cake for herself
and there's no one else
in the house now
somebody comes to the door and you find
out that it's halloween
but because her and her father have
lived in england
um they don't really celebrate it over
there or they didn't back then
uh so she's like yeah i don't really
celebrate that but it is my birthday and
i'm celebrating my birthday now the
person that's at the door
is this dude named
hallett and he is played by martin sheen
and he is [ __ ] creepy
perversion i mean just right out the
gate i mean
he doesn't even hardly make any bones
about it he's just kind of like hey i'm
gonna come in your house and like start
[ __ ] creeping on you is that okay
okay here i am so yeah um he plays a
really good villain in this he just
totally
leans into it because yeah there's i
will say that there's some real
uncomfortable because she's only 13
years old she's
the character is 13 and the actual
actress had just turned 13 when she made
this movie
sort of some kind of like uncomfortable
[ __ ] in here but
i think it works i don't think it
bothers me so much just because jody
foster
is so self-possessed
and she doesn't come across she looks
like a kid but she doesn't come across
like a kid i guess and um she comes
across
almost like she has the upper hand not
in a kind of femme fatale kind of way
but
just in a way that she's kind of smarter
than everyone else
so i guess you know that she you know
might win out in the end even though
people are kind of trying to victimize
her you know what i mean
i don't i'm not sure if that's real
clear but yeah so
so there's this creepy dude and he just
keeps coming around and finally she's
just like he's like oh my kids are out
trick-or-treating and
you know they they need some candy or
whatever and she's like well i don't
know how many candy and i'll celebrate
halloween so she's like well they can
have a couple pieces of my birthday
cake here [ __ ] off so he [ __ ] off now
it turns out
that uh creepy mccreeperson is the
son of this horrible
shrewish woman mrs hallett who
is the person that ren's dad
rented this house from for three years
and this woman
right at the beginning of the movie uh
is starting to suspect that maybe
something not entirely kosher is going
on in this house because
every time she goes over there like you
know the the dad paid
three years in advance like for this
house so they could live there
but she hasn't really seen him since
then and
every time she comes over there like to
talk to him rin's like oh he's
in new york or he's in his study or he
can't be disturbed or something she
always has some excuse as to like why
nobody can see him and they also show
her going about
doing i guess what would be considered
like adult
uh errands you know like she goes to the
bank and she's got all these travelers
checks and she's cashing them in and the
bankers are like man she's like 13 years
old and she's like
yeah but me and my dad have a joint
account it's like he said that i could
put my
signature on it so she does all that
kind of she has a safety deposit box and
like all this other kind of stuff
so you know this whole time you're
sitting there going what the [ __ ] man
with this kid
i mean it's pretty apparent right from
the beginning which i think is why
everyone starts to get suspicious
that she's living in this house by
herself but nobody really knows
what happened to the dad or what the
[ __ ] is going on or anything like that
now at one point uh the [ __ ] woman mrs
hallett
comes over there and she's kind of
really the the thing about it is that
yes i realize i don't know if she owns
this house and she's leasing it to them
or if
she's just a real estate agent i wasn't
real clear on that
um because if she's just a real estate
agent she really does she doesn't knock
or anything she just like
lets herself in she just comes on in and
she's like hey i need to talk to your
dad like
i'm like excuse me this is like my
[ __ ] okay and uh jenny foster's not
having it either she's like this is my
house it's like you can't just [ __ ]
waltz in here whatever the [ __ ] you want
to i mean she doesn't say that but
that that's well that's what she meant
so this woman
she is again trying to see wren's dad
she
you know she's like he's either not here
or he's sleeping or she always has some
excuse like i said
and so this woman is like goddammit i'm
going to report you to the school board
because you don't go to school and
something weird is going on here i don't
like it and then
she's like um i had i want to do my my
canning for the year or whatever
and she was like and i left all these
mason jars like jelly glasses like down
in the cellar and i'm gonna go get them
now at this point wren's like no you
cannot go down to the cellar so you're
like oh well obviously there's something
going on down there
now what ends up happening here is that
mrs hallett
goes down to the cellar she's like well
[ __ ] you i'm going down there anyway and
goes down there anyway
sees something down there which you
don't see screams
tries to run out the seller and then
knocks um
there's like a you know like a stick
like holding the
the cellar door up and uh she knocks it
off and
kills her full self basically like it
hits her in the head and
she falls down into the cellar at which
point rin's kind of like well [ __ ]
um no big loss i'll say that because
that woman was like
shrieking harridan and i was just kind
of like oh well
should have knocked but that's all i'm
saying but uh so yeah so ren's like well
[ __ ] now what i'm going to do because
her car is out front and everybody knows
this is a very small town and everybody
knows who this [ __ ] is
so she's like well crap um she has this
very distinctive green bentley and now
it's parked in front of this car there
are parts in front of the house
now the house is like pretty remote but
as i said it's a small town everybody
knows everybody's business
so she's like why don't i have to move
this bentley i have to like i don't know
push to the bottom of a lake or
something like that so she goes out
there and she tries to get it started
she can't get it started like while
she's out there kind of like
you know flooding the engine or whatever
it is she's doing
this kid rides by on a bike now this kid
is mario
um he's i'm not sure how old he's
supposed to be looks
considerably older than her but he does
say i don't see you in school so
i'm assuming that he's supposed to be
like 16 or 17 so it's not that weird
that they spoiler alert end up kind of
boyfriend and girlfriend
but uh you know and especially because
she's wise beyond her years i guess but
he's
still supposed to be like a junior
higher high school kid so he's
um a magician and i guess he says
something about like all his brothers
and
being like athletic but he had polio so
he's
um you know he he has like a gimpy leg
like he can't really walk he walks with
a cane
so he's basically like he comes up to
help her he's like well you want me to
help you move the car
and he's like and he knows whose car it
is um
and they kind of start hanging out
together
now it takes a while because
rin as a character is very
i mean they get into it a little bit
later on in some of the discussions that
she has with mario
but she's a very very independent person
she does not like
anyone telling her what to do she
doesn't want anyone like constraining
her movements
she doesn't want to go to school because
she calls it quote unquote stultifying
which i thought was very funny
um and like i said you took coming from
jodie foster
even a 13 year old jody foster you
totally buy it
because she is just so adult-like even
when she was 13 years old
that i didn't have any trouble at all
believing
that she was probably okay like taking
care of herself like living by herself
in this house
so as her and mario kind of get closer a
little bit of a romance develops there
um she kind of starts taking him into
her confidence
now what she says is that
basically her dad was
who was a kind of a well-known poet i
guess
and he had some kind of terminal disease
i'm assuming cancer
and he knew that he was dying and he
also knew
how extraordinary his daughter wren was
and was confident that she would be able
to take care of herself
so basically what he did was he's like
well
we have to move somewhere where nobody
knows who we are that's kind of like
this
small town or remote town where nobody
will really ask any questions or know us
all that well
um he got the house he paid for it three
years in advance so she would be able to
live there
and um basically told her you know just
don't
he told her just survive don't let him
[ __ ] you around don't let anybody uh
tell you what to do
you just do what you want and i think
you're gonna be okay
so um then he like wanders off and like
jumps in the ocean or something like
that so he killed himself
rin did not kill him however
let's let's not let brit off the off the
hook too quickly
because one other thing that the dad
said before he died
now ren's mom was abusive and
the dad was like well you know when she
finds out
that i'm dead and that you're by
yourself she's gonna come and try to get
you
so if that happens um he's like
give her some tea with this sedative in
it
take care of the problem now it's not
made
real clear whether rin actually knew it
was a sedative or what
or whether it was cyanide which it was
um
i'm inclined to think that she probably
had an inkling she wasn't dumb
so uh indeed the mother does turn up
this is not shown this happened like
before the events of the movie
so i guess the mom turns up um rin gives
her the poison tea she dies
and wren uh after doing some research at
the library embalms the body
psycho style and puts her down in the
cellar which was what mrs hallett saw
when she went down to the cellar she saw
an embalmed [ __ ] body down there she
screamed and then like she fell
on her you know the door fell on her
head
so she tells mario all of this and then
um
mario little mr accessory after the fact
he decides he's gonna help her because
they've fallen in love at this point
so um they're like well we you know
obviously people are going to start
getting suspicious we can have all these
[ __ ] bodies piling up in the cellar
so they take both the bodies the
embalmed one and uh you know the the
bitch's body
and bury them kind of outside like in
the mud or whatever
now sadly uh what happens then
is that while they're burying the bodies
it says there's a really bad storm and
it's really cold mario ends up getting
getting a cold and from that cold he
ends up getting pneumonia so he's kind
of he doesn't die
or anything like that but he does kind
of have to go to the hospital so he's
kind of out of the picture
now when this happens martin sheen's
character
the creep face has been perving around
pretty much this whole time he's been
like stalking
wren and he thinks he knows what's going
on he knows there's something suspicious
uh he wants to get in her pants he's
like super super
creepy um and he's he's good at it which
is
disturbing um and this was like before
apocalypse now this was kind of he'd
been in some stuff prior to this martin
sheen but i think this was kind of
one of his first big major roles and he
just
he just choose that scenery man he's
just he's clearly enjoying being a
perverted villain which
i'm not sure how to feel about that but
yeah
so uh so he's been creeping around this
whole time
and i guess like after mario has to go
to the hospital and then
rin is kind of left all alone again
without her partner in crime
um he decides he's gonna come back and
check out the cellar like while she's
out or whatever and he's gonna see
what's going on
now the bodies aren't in the cellar
anymore however he does find one of his
mom's very distinctive hairpins
and he finds like a broken
bright red fingernail which uh wasn't
his mom's but belonged to ren's mom so
he assumes that there was at least two
bodies
because he's not dumb either so he
assumed that there was at least two
bodies down there
so he's trying to use this as leverage
against wren
he's like hey why don't you be my little
underage sex toy says the pedo and uh
and i won't tell anybody about your
little murderous proclivities how about
that
and she's kind of like you know like i
said you know this character like
throughout this whole movie it's like
you know that she's gonna end up besting
this [ __ ] just because
he i mean he's so sleazy and creepy and
everything and throughout this whole
thing
wren's character the only time you see
her show any emotion
really is when one
um the [ __ ] martin sheen kills
her [ __ ] hamster
gordon uh in a really horrific
scene obviously they didn't kill a real
hamster
um but they did like [ __ ] with the dead
one
like you know what i mean like there's a
scene where he's he's got gordon in his
hand like oh
isn't it and that's real but then they
kind of cut away a little bit and then
he
puts out a cigarette like on the head of
a hamster and it's a dead one
that they got from like a lab or
something um so
if you're very if you're very
uncomfortable with animal
cruelty you might even though the
animal's dead it's like it's still kind
of upsetting to watch i mean i found it
very upsetting because that was a
cute-ass hamster
but yeah so um but the gordon the
hamster
was okay at the time too because i think
a member of the crew after the movie
shoot was over the gordon got adopted by
one of the members of the group so it's
fine
but uh but yeah so if that's gonna
bother you then yeah you don't wanna
watch that
um also uh but yeah so she shows emotion
then because she obviously loved that
little hamster and like to have this
[ __ ] psycho like
kill the hamster like right in front of
her to try to get information out of her
[ __ ] up and honestly i would i would
argue anybody that did
something like that i'm like i really
don't feel bad
about what she does to him at the end
you know which i'm just i'm just saying
but uh so yeah so she gets upset about
that but the only other time she
she shows any emotion whatsoever is when
she visits mario in the hospital he's
unconscious
um you know he's got pneumonia and um
she admits to him
as much as she tried to do everything by
herself and you know she was up like i
said she's always very self-possessed
and try to do everything alone all the
time
she's kind of crying and saying to his
like unconscious
face that um you know i can't do it
alone i can't do it without you
um you know because because he because
she loved him and he was helping her out
yeah so so she's just like this very i
i hesitate to use the word cold
she's just very resolute she's very
determined and she's very
certain that she's not going to let
others as i said victimize her even
though she's a kid
it's really this movie is almost kind of
like a treatise on children's rights
because she does kind of say a lot of
things along those lines during this
movie it's like oh just because i'm 13
you can just bust in my house
and you know do whatever you want like
to go down in my cellar and [ __ ] like
that
so she does she does say a lot of things
about that like that
just because she's 13 doesn't mean you
can just like walk over walk all over
her you know what i mean so in that way
she's kind of like a really
uh relatable character even though she
does kill people but like i said
you know she killed her mom which
you're hearing it from her and her dad's
perspective so
maybe that wasn't maybe she didn't know
it was poison
although i suspect she probably did um
she didn't kill mrs hallett mrs hallett
uh
killed her own self like accidentally
she did hide the body okay
now martin sheen's character she does
kill that [ __ ] but he killed a
hamster and he's a creepo perv
so [ __ ] him pretty much so basically so
what he does at the end like i said he
finds out like all
he found he finds this stuff in her
cellar and is you know
assumes that he has killed because
obviously he knows his mother was
missing and uh they found her car just
parked in front of the office and nobody
knows where she went to
because that's where they left her car
so he's basically using that as
blackmail material
um to get her to
like i said be his underage sex toy
which gross
so she kind of pretends like she's gonna
go along with it like yeah okay i guess
so blah blah blah
and then she goes in the kitchen starts
making some tea and i'm just like oh
yeah
it's [ __ ] cyanide payback time now
she even does something
clever because she knows that martin
sheen
will figure out that she's probably
gonna poison his ass
so she puts the poison in her cup
princess bride style
you know what i mean so it's so she puts
it in her cup she brings out the tray
and everything and
uh you know and she's always like yeah
we're gonna take he's like why aren't
you drinking it
and she's like oh i'll drink it you know
they but then like he's like no
i'm gonna switch the cups and then and
then she's probably like yes but she
doesn't say that
because he's i think he thinks that he's
smarter than her
but he's not smarter than her but yeah
so she ends up poisoning him
and uh he man i guess
he's uh you got to give him something
because he's like creeping on her right
to the end like right as he's dying and
he's just like oh [ __ ] she poisoned me
and she's like
your hair is so pretty and like all this
other stuff i'm like
that's determination like sticking to
the perv like right to the end
i i guess that's something and uh but
the final shot is so great because it's
just like jody foster
it's just kind of a close-up of her face
looking very impassively at him
like as he [ __ ] as he's poisoned to
death and he's like choking and stuff
and i'm just like yeah yeah get that
[ __ ]
but yeah now i will say from what i've
heard and like i said i haven't read the
book
but i read several reviews of it that
kind of went over the plot a little bit
now i think
in the book rin was
less sympathetic of a character because
i think in the book
she actually not only killed her mom
like i think in the same way that she
killed her in the movie
but i think she also deliberately killed
mrs hallett which even if she had in the
movie i'd be like nah
she was a [ __ ] too it's like you know
what i mean i wouldn't have felt all
that bad
you know what i mean but i think she
deliberately killed her in the book so i
think
in the movie they tried to make her a
little bit more of a sympathetic
character
rather than you know a demon child or
whatever
but you know i i don't know it doesn't
come across it's really weird because i
think it usually gets lumped in with a
lot of other kind of killer kid
sort of movies but she doesn't come
across like that at all she does come
across as very calculating
and very um you know hey don't get my
like don't [ __ ] with me like don't get
in my way or something bad will happen
to you
but not in any malicious way she's not
malignantly killing people she's just
she wants to maintain
her life she wants to live alone in this
house just like her dad wanted for her
and anybody that interferes with that
she's gonna do something about it that's
kind of all
the you know what i mean so it's kind of
all um
that's going on there now when i
mentioned
very early at the beginning of the
review that there was a controversy
about this and perhaps it's
more of a controversy i guess in
american film as opposed to european
film because like i said this is
a hungarian-born director who mostly
worked in france
and european movies tend not to have as
much
um you know they tend not to get as
upset about large age differences or
about things like that
so there is a scene in this movie
where jody foster's character wren
uh where her and mario her boyfriend who
is i don't know like i said i don't know
how much older he's supposed to be than
her she's 13.
he's still in school obviously but um
you know so i guess that's not as weird
but it's still kind of weird
because she's so young but it's not like
he's
30 or anything like that he's supposed
to be a high school kid
so um so the scene where both of them
have sex now
they don't show it's not a graphic sex
scene or anything like that
but they do show the character of ren
taking her clothes off and you see her
from the back naked
and um you kind of see like the
silhouette like of her boob and stuff
like that now
don't be alarmed that was not actually
jody foster obviously they couldn't do
that
um it was actually her older sister
connie who
stood in for her uh as a body double and
for other things
on some of her other movies as well
connie was i believe either 19 or 21
when this movie was shot so it's a
little weird like seeing this scene
where
what's supposed to be a 13 year old girl
and then like you see this back of a
naked
woman that's clearly older so it's a
little strange
now i think that jody foster
um from what i've heard she really
really argued to have the scene taken
out because she was like i don't you
know it doesn't really need to be in
there it's just kind of like weird and
creepy
and i think that many years later she
sort of disowned this movie
particularly because they wouldn't take
it out uh the producers
for whatever reason i mean i'm sure i
can think of probably what the reason is
but uh but they did not want to take the
scene out and indeed it is still in
there um even if you watch the amazon
prime version i think there are some
versions where it's been cut out but if
you watch it on amazon prime it's still
there
like i said it's not it's not graphic
it's not anything like that it's just
like the back of a naked woman that is
clearly not jody foster uh it's her
sister
who was of age at the time so it's not
like there's a naked 13 year old girl in
it
um i will say that i don't even though i
don't find it
you know all that scandalous it probably
didn't need to be in there
um it's just a very throwaway it's only
like a few seconds 30 seconds a minute
or something like before she gets into
bed with mario
so i don't really know why it had to be
in there
um so i can kind of see why jd foster
was mad uh you know because it kind of
embarrassed her she was only 13 at the
time and you know she was like i don't
you know please take it out but they
wouldn't take it out so like i said she
kind of uh
doesn't really you know [ __ ] with this
movie anymore
but you know your mileage may vary i'm
just telling you that that's in there so
if that's gonna bother you
um or the animal cruelty thing is gonna
bother you with the hamster
then maybe not but other other than that
i really really like this movie there's
just something
so creepy i don't know like about the
atmosphere of it and jody foster is
[ __ ] amazing in it i mean you can
really see i mean she was amazing and
taxi driver she was amazing at all
you know everybody knew what amazing
actor she was when she was even when she
was very very young it was very apparent
but she just brought something to this
role that was just like
it was perfect it was just like a
perfect
like i said you totally bought not only
that she was a 13 year old kid
which she was but she came across as
just so
adult and so mature that you also
totally bought
that she could do all this [ __ ] that she
could totally live by herself that she
could
you know just sort her own life out
because she just really seemed to have
her [ __ ] together like more than some
adults i know
even nowadays you know what i mean so
it's like so the fact that she could
pull that off i think it's
like a tour de force performance because
it's i mean the most of the movie
revolves around her there are some other
characters and she interacts with other
characters quite a bit
i know there's a cop that she befriends
also who is mario's uncle
who's actually really nice to her um you
know and the creep and
the [ __ ] and everything but i mean this
is mostly
her movie um you know martin sheen
probably the second biggest role and i
guess the guy that played mario
um probably the third biggest but
it really is kind of you know the whole
movie kind of rests on her shoulders
and you know and her acting performance
really really
makes this work so yeah if you haven't
seen it
it's from 1976 as i said it's uh
you know don't go into it expecting like
a horror horror movie it's not
scary it's more unsettling
in a way that a lot of it kind of gives
me the same vibe as
like the other which we also talked
about from 1972. it's just this real
i don't know there's just this real
off-putting like unsettling eerie kind
of
vibe to it and there's like you know a
mystery about you know
it it feels like something sinister is
always going on you're not entirely sure
what
so it's just like a really really good
atmosphere like that which i think a lot
of movies from
that era have which is probably why i
like a lot of them so much
but yeah this is uh definitely one to
check out if you haven't seen it like i
said it's a little bit of a forgotten
uh movie and jody foster doesn't really
like to talk about it anymore and like i
said i can't
i can't entirely blame her i get where
she's coming from
with that but it is a really great
acting performance it's a really cool
little story little mystery um you know
and
definitely one i would recommend so if
you have
amazon prime uh it is on there at least
as of this recording used to be on hulu
i don't think it is anymore sadly
um but i'm sure you can get it somewhere
else if you want to see it and that will
do it for
this movie retrospective hopefully tom
will be back for the next one and i'll
see you next time
bye